how old are you 28. damn
1987.
[Music]
I'm constant that and these are my 10
essential items
you know what I'm saying the snacks all
right look hold on hold on hold on
before y'all come for me you feel what
I'm saying cause my chat my my when I'm
in my stream this evening as soon as
they see a rebel it's like attic you're
addicted you're addicting this [ __ ] I'll
be just be drinking November because I
don't I ain't gonna lie like it be
giving me energy let's be helping
sometimes you know get you through your
day a little bit and [ __ ] like that then
you got chips or more usually I got the
milk with this this is too OD like this
or milk I could never just eat this
straight I gotta have milk with it hey
yo yo y'all got some milk in here
something like y'all oh my God oh my
gosh oh oh you didn't tell me twice
and look please don't put your cookies
in the in the milk for too long maximum
like five seconds you just gotta have it
in there for like five seconds scrubbing
around real quick or else the other
half's gonna drop in you see what I'm
saying and then like you know it's time
to eat
oh my God Perfect all right the next one
this is probably like my top favorite
drinks right now I ain't gonna like
Capri Sun this is so perfect because
it's like a certain amount of juice in
here and like when you finish it you
just want more and when it's cold it's
easy you feel what I'm saying you could
nothing it's time to drink
yo y'all want some Caprice
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it's all about hygiene you feel what I'm
saying Sarah V for the face the cleanser
and the lotion you feel what I'm saying
gotta make sure the the smooth skin is
there you know the ladies like the
smooth skin so you look good you feel
good you feel me that native this right
here is very important because I should
be going there should be no reason why
I'm going to clubs and in public events
and people be smiling funky I can't be
that person Gotta Have native I'm not
gonna lie oh other deodorants make my
skin kind of burn or itch because I
think I don't know what the ingredients
in it but this is like natural you feel
what I'm saying and it smells good so
ballistics been getting it since a kid
ballistics I've never finished a full
job this day so I don't know what be
happening to my ballistics like it
always disappeared like right after like
I'm about to finish it but this is
essential gotta make sure you know my
lips is not chapped and it's and it's
good to go
foreign next essential is
my wallet you know I need this wallet
this wallet holds a lot of things I
can't go nowhere without this like I
cannot leave the cream without my wallet
there's a few things that y'all gonna
see here that I can't leave the crib
without I'm telling you this is
definitely one of them uh ID I got I got
my ID I got my cars can't show that you
feel what I'm saying I got um you know
my insurance card you for me um I also
got
um skin condoms indeed
growing up I couldn't even get nothing
like this so like when I have something
like this it'd be fine like it reminds
me like yo okay you you feel what I'm
saying is you you go afford this now you
know
[Music]
my next essential I ain't gonna lie to
jewelry you know what I'm saying if you
look good you feel good and I love I
love doing
um when I go out to special occasions I
love having a junior you know rose gold
and people don't know this a lot of
people don't know this
get in there right there you know and
obviously KC stand for constant that I
actually have my supporters you know
SketchUp you know some designs and I
just chose the best design and then just
ended up being the best one then after
that you know I took it to Izzy you know
NYC luxury Izzy and um he went crazy
with this with this piece like this is
the original bust that rolly Avalanche
like you feel what I'm saying something
I'm Courtside and stuff it'd be it'd be
it'll be going crazy when I go in our
travel places okay down music and just
in case I go into a special occasion you
know I gotta have it on I'll put it on
like this
feeling like I'm gonna you feel what I'm
saying right now you know I'm pretty
handsome right now but like right now
when I put this on it's like hit
sometimes too you know this watch is not
to tell the time this watch is when
you're walking when you walk in the room
you know what time it is
this right here now this is a combo
right here you got your your phone I
don't need a phone but you gotta have
the pods too I wouldn't be able to do a
lot of things that I do now if I didn't
have this phone right here you feel what
I'm saying this get me through a lot of
things I'm able to contact people make
some moves and stuff like that and also
you feel what I'm saying kind of close
some joints you feel what I'm saying I
miss them up a little bit I couldn't
drink right now so I won't close during
right now see what they say
your call has been oh never mind yeah
yo yo
skip that
I like twitch you know twitch Twitch app
TV see how the community is doing and
then like my social media ads probably
like I like Instagram Twitter the worst
apartment app in high school was you
feel me uh math Papa if you know you
know
[ __ ] how old are you damn
1986 damn 28 is crazy this [ __ ] don't
even look 28 that's the crazy part yeah
my next essential item is
y'all always see me on [ __ ] with the
like Eric Emmanuel see what I'm saying
you know what I'm saying
let's get into the clothes shit's as big
as hell God [ __ ] damn damn
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying gotta have
a fresh white cheese like a white teas
is a it's a must and again I prefer
hands too like I ain't gonna love it
usually I have like you know a Yankee
hat I'll be having a Yankee hat with
this one it's my go-to so I'll be having
this my and y'all be on my ass because I
have a rotational if you notice every
few streams I put on the same [ __ ] I'm
not about to be looking for a new fit
every stream I'm in my crimp fan you see
what I'm saying but I'll be having these
and then I go live you look like a
basketball player with these on here you
know I could hope though you feel me
anybody that want to know if you want me
on the court let me know I'm killing you
by like like 30. I'm dropping 30 on you
my next essential is my top you know
tools I use right now out of this whole
list is one God gotta keep God first if
you know him nothing to be going on I'm
very religious I grew up in church
um
against us and lead us not to temptation
but lyrics with evil amen you feel what
I'm saying so yeah I like to say a
little our father or hail Mary hey gotta
pray no matter no matter what your
religion is make sure you praying then
Mama Dukes let me call my dukes right
now my mom she's a Superhero
she got an answer hello
you on TV you want TV
yeah say what's up
what's up what's up everybody mama's
gonna in the house
you know GQ
[Music]
yeah yeah
right here like cameras lights
everything
indeed indeed
top three fragrances no you know that's
like that's like asking what's the you
know Krabby Patty secret formula you
know what I'm saying chill you know what
I'm saying that's for y'all to explore
you can't get that up because once you
get that up everybody smells like you I
like to have my own fragrance and then
everybody don't even know what it is but
they but I walk through they'd be like
oh snap can't see in the building I
didn't know you two better the degree
the Degree deodorant that was crazy you
know what I'm saying with the with the
ax spray at the gym I ain't gonna like
this smell good though he should spray
like everywhere like make sure that [ __ ]
you feel what I'm saying I'm smelling
awesome on the height but um yeah that's
not it no more
[Music]
the mafia now if you don't know about
the mafia that that's that's who I call
my supporters they either go by uh km
Kai Mafia or just Mafia you know what
I'm saying and they are really important
to my life because without them things
wouldn't be happening right now without
them that's how I feel like people feel
to realize no matter how big you get in
life you always gotta remember who was
there to support you in the first place
so the mafia was like really heavy
without them there is no me so shout out
to everybody who supported me from the
start I'm talking about from Facebook
days I just want to let y'all know that
I love y'all they know that though I
tell them that all the time but without
them I'm nobody you know when I grow we
grow as one and um yeah shout out to
Mafia That's they're really important to
me
my next essential item is indeed
a camera you feel what I'm saying gotta
have the cam you know what I'm saying
these I don't look at these like as if
I'm spending money these are investments
you feel me this is gonna these are
investments that's gonna you know
eventually make me money and like I get
them to Capture Moments to put online
and these are just it's just it's just
coming in for itself so I would suggest
like people because I can get some on
camera but don't look at it as you
spread your money you're looking as
you're messing this can be used for
videos all my flicks behind the scenes
content like it's a lot of [ __ ] that
could go into this you feel what I'm
saying and if I have my camera you feel
what I'm saying usually not trying to
tell you no 10 out of 10. you see me
recording you're also gonna see my
cameraman too so he on that good thing
you feel what I'm saying Chris he didn't
lead him in for amp too you feel what
I'm saying so not only my channel
that's what you want to do
what you want to do bro okay I'm on this
table you can get this out of here I'm
gonna get started okay hold on
yeah hello
has anybody ever danced on GQ
oh I bet
[Music]
hold on
damn thing
those are not against them you know what
I'm saying big New York [ __ ]
you can see the camera
do your [ __ ] man yes sir I'm tired I'm
not a [ __ ] bro God damn yo GQ
thank you guys for having me
um and I'll see y'all soon